[Music]
there is no doubt camila cabello shut
down the vma stage but she had a little
help from boyfriend shawn mendes give it
up for my guys
[Applause]
on sunday night the musical power couple
performed back to back at the 2021 mtv
video music awards with camilla kicking
things off with her song don't go yet
giving vintage black and white
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the singer later surprised us with a pop
of color in this unexpected dance move
[Music]
camilla then turned the stage over to
sean who gave us all the feels while
performing his song summer of love
alongside taney
[Music]
and we can't help but think that sean
was singing directly to camilla with
this romantic lyrics
[Applause]
last year sean told et that when it
comes to getting mushy in music camilla
doesn't mind i think we're both equally
very mushy and i think we're both
extremely mushy people we're both super
sensitive which is creates a lot of
sensitive sensitivity in our
relationship but we are songwriters so
we're constantly searching for the
sensitive topics in the life and um
i don't know i'm pretty mushy i feel
like she would maybe say i'm much more
mushy and in august camilla revealed to
et what it's like having shawn by her
side amid their busy careers has it been
fun to have sean cheering you on as your
real-life prince
totally i mean he's uh you know he's the
best and i think we're really supportive
of each other and he was there for the
whole beginning of it and
was so supportive and
yeah i'm lucky i have awesome people
[Music]
you